[Music]
good morning socially and by the way
this has a little film on the top of
this one the older mug so you're a fan I
sprayed it with Obon yeah it comes in
spray if it's an anti sanitizer
really I think we give it a try the
opposite of what you would like would
today we have a bunch to get to today
yes we have Joe Biden the raping we have
more when you have some more updates
uncooked and we have a live roast with
our Jocko correspondent of Jocko
Willington on the show later today
but first we have my half-asian lawyer
bill Richman here too low who compared
to everybody else he stands very erect
do you understand yes correct for the
kingdom he protects much higher to
please his royal sire yes the ballerinas
must pirouette somebody help me teddy
bears must make the Kings forget that
was the gayest remember that this Arthur
this is the show guys reference
burgermeister meisterburger let me know
if you understand what I'm talking about
by the way we will be reading your chat
live my collection of the day for you is
this is the last good morning mug Club
Buckhorn teen month of course hashtag
mug Club corn real you can enter in the
promo code quarantine you get $30 off
until the end of day tomorrow yes and if
you want some more good morning my club
when we come back we're taking one week
off next week we've talked about that
let us know let us know if you'd like us
to do more of these going forward if you
want a hybrid of this and the late night
you know it's an experiment it's one big
experiment the feedback a lot of fun
quarter black Garrett is here audio Wade
is here panicking about something not
panning into gurbles over there Morgan
no wine for you today no wine it's too
early for well no it's not Wow
I just judged millions out there holding
glasses or quarantine as a promo code of
course subscribe to Crowder bits on the
YouTube in the podcast a lot of people
oh no you can download the podcasts on
audio here the Apple podcasts the
Android sound Spotify the the podcasts
stitcher the Cricket Wireless Catcher in
the Rye dangerous really an overrated
podcast
it really is it's really an overrated
mechanism the pod Catcher in the Rye
anyone your wretched have to read that
like I don't understand how that appeals
to unless you're a serial killer I
thought it was just punishment uh by the
way chat only for muggle members they're
watching live at blaze TV I'm having a
good week so far yeah a lot of fun
gearing up for tomorrow tomorrow in line
for our live stream of the briefing and
fact-checking the CN n I don't know why
we do this to ourselves
it really is your fault that's because
we can all remain employed that's true
okay fine speaking of which poppy Harlow
is on Oh chromevox notice that on CNN
there's like nineteen minutes of
commercials yeah yeah alright so we have
a few stories to get to the big one
obviously and I was kind of keeping it
under my ah it's about a YouTube and
Facebook coming together to remove the
wrong things they had some doctors there
you know from Berkeley Cal Berkeley
California from Baker's fake homes thank
you sorry
feel there and it's not even Fresno and
they got their stuff removed or they
were talking of the patients that they
were treating but first before that
remember the the chloroquine the fish
tank cleaner lady and we said that she
actually hated Donald Trump she hated
her husband exposed and she knew that it
was not chloroquine it was fish tank
cleaner and then we called the NBC
reporter who was you know quart sort of
the original source for this we said you
know I think this woman's a new Caryl
Baskin 2.0 someone should run an
investigation into this broad well guess
what now it's happening fish tank
cleaner ladies being investigated for
homicide
[Music]
one and we called it early early early
on all of us were like this sounds a
little weird well it turned out now the
husband so she to be clear to recap she
said that she drank fish tank cleaner
her and her husband they both drank it
together like a Romeo and Juliet really
yeah yeah only it was really just was
really just if Juliet said okay Romeo
down the gullet fish cleaners good fish
tank cleaners right behind ya drink mine
just a minute and then John Leguizamo is
speaking in Shakespearean was he you me
I was he in them Romeo and Juliet with
slavery Canada I don't think so it was
terrible but so that so she the original
Stroh is she loves Donald Trump's so she
trusted Donald Trump and they both drank
fish tank cleaner her husband
unfortunately died and no one else
should trust Donald Trump we did some
digging
turns out she hates Donald Trump she's
an anti-trump activists she's donated to
Democrats and she actually hated her
husband she has a history of a domestic
abuse she was charged with it she has a
history of violence she has a history of
mental health disorders and now we know
that her husband turns out was actually
a really smart engineer now you know
dumb guy you would assume if she drink
this fish tank cleaner he'd have a
couple questions
it's like no I just want to make sure is
this one of those moments where you love
me or yeah exactly
you know it also could just be might
investigating find out it was a suicide
she's like hey do you want to drink this
yes my will is giving it all to charity
like a Warren Buffett you get nothing
oh so he was an engineer yeah and now
they're investigating it for homicide
well what's funny is that all we were
doing was really digging into this to
prove a point like this person didn't do
this because of Donald Trump like that
would that was the story joking I was
half joking and now thank you very very
prophetic did you have anything else on
the I thought you're bringing up the
well I have the article in here but yeah
a whole lot of information right now the
Mesa City Police Department they are
investigating it they're just saying
that they can't say anything right now
because it is an ongoing investigation
and so that means like okay this is that
they're just like taking a kind of a
quick look at it they've actually opened
an investigation into this and so I
guarantee we're gonna find out something
shady went down here yeah we don't know
a whole lot about it and you know it
again the
the same things that that reporter could
have done or you like 75 other outlets
right we're like yeah that sounds
totally know maybe because Don Lemon
sniffer is stuffed with cocaine and ass
hairs what's the thing really no I don't
think it but it could be and if someone
were to do that thing that would be Don
Lemon brian Stelter is part of a
primetime lineup he's part of the lineup
it includes brett brian Stelter here's
the thing i don't despise you okay and
just for the record everyone knows I'd
never challenge any of them - except for
Chris Cuomo because it's go to was like
I'll kick your ass okay pick me pick me
um but brian Stelter you are in a lineup
that includes Don Lemon Anderson Cooper
and you are clearly the gayest that's a
matter fact I think of everything else
through that it's like it's not even a
lens it's like a cheesecloth I just
Stelter is kit all I see is the fact
that he's the least talented of the
three yeah it's hard to really focus on
anything else
Chris Cuomo is is vying for that title
ya know but not to be outdone but I at
least can laugh at him yes Stelter I'm
sad for him Stelter is like he's
unwatchable to me yeah I could watch
Cuomo a little bit and I would just hate
what he's saying but when I see Stelter
talk I just did something about it and
then really quickly I want to move on to
the YouTube and Facebook removing these
doctors videos but right now we go to
CNN look these airlines are now
demanding that all passengers wear masks
this is remarkable because I was driving
down the freeway today and I saw one of
those what are those billboards at
digital billboards they would have
rotate yeah and it was saying wear your
masks yeah and well second you told us
the opposite of that you said it was
dangerous to wear masks and by the way
we questioned the experts here yeah you
know what if you know how to wear a mask
we try to instruct on how to put it on
properly it can protect other people the
Surgeon General said no no no no no no
no don't believe the conspiracies online
trust the world health authorities and
us and now they're out there too they
want to make it illegal to not wear them
exactly and it's like the airlines are
like the last four people on earth to
realize that it's a flying petri dish
right that we should probably take some
precautions well
there's just recycled yeah and you know
the the crazy part is if you go back and
look I've started doing this a little
bit of the folks are the most vehement
about you know Trump has told us to
inject Lysol etcetera and they can write
repeating these claims and I actually do
it's like this game of telephone where
someone has passed an article the past
opposed the past another word about the
end it's like so you know we decided
we're gonna take baths and Lysol we're
gonna drink it everyday like a regimen
and then we're gonna use our which is
smelling candle Thank You Gwyneth
Paltrow but when you go back and look at
was I don't know that I thank her no no
okay I take that back yeah but when you
look at people who have posted about
this these are the exact same people who
thirty sixty days ago we're going if you
buy a mask and you wear it right now you
are destroying America right it is right
yeah hello guys wait so when did we
decide that masks you're causing more
harm than good
exactly said surgical masks that were an
n95 masks were harmful and then they
were like you know what you can make it
from a t-shirt or a scarf
wait what hold up you guys said not to
wear the actual masks and now you're
telling us how to make a mask oh the
Kondos the condescension that comes with
if you're gonna try and make a mask at
home know if you don't have an n95
you're a communist right looks so
terrible you're protecting yourself and
you're not exactly so it was don't wear
a mask now make sure you wear mask but
if you don't wear the right mass we're
gonna judge you and the only thing
that's a comment between then in the
middle and now is judging judging
judging is true you know the worst thing
about this whole pandemic is the
judgment also the deaths but let's go to
norsu let's go to the the story of
YouTube in Facebook
wait are you here are you with us audio
wait he's so happy I know what's going
on he always panicked now show
disappears then he shows up like 30
minutes in history he's gonna pounce in
just a minute and steal your soul means
very much I told you you can't keep
audio it happy because then he just sits
there contend it's also why is no longer
a lot on public transit Oh
what are you doing nothing sir yes
everybody scared of that guy I just ride
the L train back into the station and
back out so this really is disturbing we
talked about it yesterday and when I
talked about it I think it had only been
removed from YouTube or Facebook one or
the other now it's been removed from
both had over five million plays okay so
this this was a video clip of two
doctors in Bakersfield California who
run an urgent care clinic and they were
talking about the thousands of patients
with kovat who they had treated what
they had observed and they were
expressing their opinions on what they
thought would be the appropriate course
of action moving forward YouTube and
Facebook determined it to be a violation
of their community guideline on
believing and they removed it so because
I double dog dare you to remove it here
I want this to live on forever let's see
a little bit of this clip we've both
been to the ER through swine flu and
through bird flu did we shut down for
those were they much less dangerous than
kovat is the flu less dangerous than
Kelvin let's look at the death rates no
it's not they're similar in prevalence
and in death rate so we are saying that
our response now now that we know the
facts it's time to get back to work
when someone what's interesting to me
too is when someone dies in this country
right now they're not talking about the
high blood pressure the diabetes the
stroke they say did they die from covett
coke there's as you we've been to
hundreds of autopsies you you don't talk
about one thing you talk about Co
morbidities their vessels were narrowed
their lungs were a smoker kovat was part
of it it is not the reason they died
folks okay calm down there Himmler what
is that they're saying what this show
has been saying the whole month right
well technically also last month yeah we
honestly artifis why do you think we
haven't been removed do you think it's
because you've gotten a little litigious
um I think yes frankly I think it's
changed because he said he thought his
channel was still up because of you yeah
that's a common sense oh did I send them
an invoice or my invoice
for work I don't know that I perform but
I think I but let's look at these
numbers really is anything that they're
saying wrong cuz it's a violation of
Community Guidelines now I could
understand if it's a violation of
Community Guidelines because what he
just said was false right like if he's
sending someone with an ar-15 into a
pizza parlor for a basement that is not
gonna be there that would be a bad thing
I think we'd all agree no no no no no
don't go in with a semi-automatic rifle
into a pizza parlor if they don't have a
basement if they have a basement we
leave the choice to you in the 2016-2017
season there were over 61,000 flu deaths
okay and this is what was still
remarkable when you research this and I
encourage anyone else to do it see
original estimates were 80,000 there
were 80,000 deaths and those were
actually they weren't estimates they
were listed and then they reduced them
right so that gives you an idea as to
and then do that almost every single
year with flu deaths by the way because
we do not measure death rates very
effectively in this country so they go
Oh flu deaths then they go oh wait a
second the guy had lung cancer and they
take it off the list undoubtedly that
should happen with the coronavirus death
especially since flu deaths have gone
down to zero and they're all registers
coronavirus deaths right so the same
thing should apply here so that's
actually correct and then if you look
the antibody study to us now some people
are saying or not valid but nothing has
been valid at this point you have your
testing hasn't been valid the numbers
from China haven't been valid we have
many different antibody tests right now
we have I think like a hundred and sixty
something anybody test now they'll
haven't all been cleared by the FDA some
are giving us too many false positives
I'll grant you that but even then let's
split the difference it's still a
fraction of what you thought all of
these tests indicate a 0.5% death rate
right hops you know who else said that
Cuomo that's what he quoted 0.5% death
rate which I thought was weird because I
calculated I always try and take the
most conservative number or the number
that gives the left sort of the most
amount of leeway when we do this because
otherwise people will fact check us this
happened it went back to Detroit when I
said the unemployment rate actually was
the other way so the unemployment rate
was twenty seven point five percent go
back to my original video and then
someone came out today actually it's
twenty eight point one it's like oh I'm
sorry it took three weeks to produce it
was 45 percent oh my god it is half of
all people in Detroit were unemployed so
now the whole country is Detroit
your utopia is now the rest of the
country we can all to soon be Detroit we
don't want no flu is generally 0.1% so
0.5% to 0.1% high in 20.5 the flu is
0.1% and this is pretty important too
not only was this censored and then I'll
toss the audience here but there was a
Medical Research Center they announced
that plans to look into UV light therapy
similar to what Donald trying to
describe you know now he said it best
lights
he didn't say yeah they could be
Christmas lights because listen it can
be Christmas all year long if you keep
it in your lungs folks and YouTube
removed the company's video describing
the treatment this is about endoscopy
where they go down your throat and they
could actually put you right into your
lungs to clear it out that was also
removed this is a video of a company
that is working on this treatment right
now him and that is removed as
misinformation they didn't even make
claims yet they're just saying hey this
is something we're scouring it could
work so doctors who are seeing patients
five million plays removed Facebook
YouTube by the way how much do you want
about the Facebook and Google had a
meeting um yes not one that they would
ever admit right sounds right I had a
meeting about contact tracing by the way
we're gonna remove doctors who are
skeptical agree with that Imperial
doctor guy Ferguson fellow from England
well of course we knew that but that so
that's the juxtaposition right now
you've got two doctors who have come out
and said guys all we're doing is
presenting the only data that we have
available mhm and it doesn't line up
with somebody who came out and said I
don't actually have data I have a model
right I have a model that has been
historically horrific Lee I was wrong
not hundreds of thousands million
million deaths off right every single
time we run this thing it's bad and
they're coming out and saying these guys
these guys don't need a platform because
they're not agreeing with the models
that we have right in the only criticism
that's being leveled against them right
now is the hair plugs warning that
really bad plugs may be right but
they've been attacked universally by
just about everybody in fact my wife was
very upset about this last night because
people were attacking them but not
saying why your wife's always obsessed
up next to you what that's usually a
happy by the way has anyone here ever
had their wife getting mad at them for
something you did in their nightmare
yeah everywhere God was like you are an
insane person this isn't me I didn't do
it it was it's a figment of your
imaginary sect but the only criticism is
that these are all people who presented
with symptoms or who were somewhat
symptomatic thinking they needed to get
a test well yeah if 80% of people are
asymptomatic wouldn't that way over
counterbalance that number right so
maybe they're saying that this isn't a
representative sample but it actually
doctor foul cheese doctor Falchi an
expert sure absolutely
yeah he hasn't seen a patient in 20
years right people should patients every
single day shouldn't we have one person
out there isn't one person out there
whose data is being included who is
actually seeing of sick patients and
able to follow up on them and in the
craziest part about this is it's not
that we're saying this person is right
we're saying you should consider the
data that they are providing from being
boots on the ground right every single
day these sources whether it's left or
right are saying we should take some
information empirical data from the
hospitals and use that information to
better create our models and understand
what we're doing
except here YouTube is said well this
one doesn't match our agenda right let's
just go ahead right keep that one out it
doesn't add a World Health Organization
right exactly in its but even think
about what the World Health Organization
does all they do is they go ask other
doctors hey so what are you seeing out
there tell us what your data hold on a
second I don't want to be fact-checked
okay I never asked for input from
Taiwanese doctors oh that's okay fair
it's fair when it's offered they that
doesn't overlap enough and I know which
is I want circles there's no Taiwan sir
way up all we want to do is hear all
people want to do is be able to hear it
and understand it and make their own
decisions right but instead Susan
Wojcicki has decided that she is the
arbiter of truth yeah as it relates to
health information also you know what
this is I'm feel like a teacher pass
your notes
gurbles and uh
handle the chat audio there's all these
funny things with air and then he shuts
up on air and it's like people will
never know how funny he is well they
should know we should just get their
love notes and readable yeah we should
we just drew tits
that's tits with coal bed hey real quick
can we turn on to CNN real quick okay
did y'all hear about all of this so yeah
you know de Blasio decides to quote how
funny is it to see sideburns next to a
surgical mask I'm sorry I don't know
districts just a funny visual it is a
funny visual it'd be like seeing an
Amish man with a with a SmartWatch
there's just something bizarre it's two
universes colliding go ahead so look at
this message my message to the Jewish
community so you had a number of folks
going there are hundreds of thousands of
Orthodox Jews in New York and a couple
hundred decide to go celebrate a rabbi
and a funeral all of them wearing masks
you know certainly not engaging in
social distancing even though you know
there are tens of thousands of other
people who are every single day in the
city of New York who were getting
together who were not getting just on a
subway the Palacio actually went down
there and then said a series of tweets
it was like hey all of you Jews you're
doing things badly and all the rest you
know like all the rest of the city was
like okay wait a minute
it's doing something wrong okay but you
decided to call us out yeah like you're
gonna just call us out over this I don't
know this sounds crazy you sent the
police to disperse us on grounds that
you're not doing on anything else what
does this remind it wasn't the police it
was actually just ill on Omar and a face
mask on Omar in riot gear someone tried
to put a daisy in her rifle and she blew
him away sitting on the sidelines like
put me in coach no L on Omar you know
listen oh my god she's in New York maybe
she could bit I'm hit by a truck but we
don't want that no class ever say one of
you also I would imagine that the
sideburn curls would protect the the
virus from getting in your ears I don't
know don't know this for if the hair in
your nether region is designed to keep
bacteria from getting into the places
that you don't want them to oh so that's
what there's probably a hygienic reason
for the curls until
we do that it was just how do how do
once attacks Jews do the curls do they
hate gotta be right those little like
things in there make em hot are they are
are the men going to sleep like earlier
old man Bugs Bunny with the curlers in
this I used to be a side sleeper ah
somebody comes to the door late at night
opening the door and trying to like
trying to yeah just hiding behind the
most exciting part is how many we're
gonna find out how many acidic juicer we
talk about some like small niche thing
and then you go to the comments of the
comments are like hey well I am yeah I
had a fan one time approached me her I
can't remember her name but was a very
very jewy name she was very nice and she
was a fan and she asked me to sign some
stuff there's a site was a call at
yeshiva world it's a big Orthodox Jewish
website yeah she's like hey you know
what my son's a big fan and she came up
and she was you know gave me a pen and
everything well thank you so much and I
went to give her a hug and she turned
white as it goes oh really
and you can't I didn't know I didn't
know yeah before coronavirus oh honey I
wasn't it was okay federal so you think
you were Joe Biden she was like I can't
I was like what do you mean and she
didn't explain it at first just like ah
Jew okay she was like my husband doesn't
find out what are you talking about your
husband is a finite like I didn't what
do you what yeah my hands are there
above shoulder level we can't touch and
I didn't know that so this this is a
perfect example of I broke the rules I'm
sorry but it doesn't stem from hate no
it stems from me living in the Western
world not being a Hasidic Jew and I
didn't know and now if I see the curls I
will refrain from hugging
I'll do the elbow hmm high five yeah Wow
but she sent me a follow-up email she's
okay just so you know I overreacted and
I was like I'm over this correct can we
just pause on that real quick I mean
isn't that the moment where someone has
made a decision to say hey she
overreacted she wanted to apologize for
it she didn't act like
crazy person right call the police and
like sue you over it or get on CNN and
say I just want to let you know this guy
who didn't know about my culture and
also I didn't bother to tell him decided
to do a thing that he shouldn't have
realistically known was a problem I
should have known I should have been
more educated well did you know that
that was different everyone here know
that you cannot touch the North
adductors okay no so it is ignorant sad
offense and look it is it ignorant is a
defense when you're living a life with
other people and cultures that are mixed
together and not being it read Yeah
right like it's true and I don't mean
you I mean yeah you don't mean me right
no Dex doesn't apply right it's
somewhere in there but I will never take
the trip up ben shapiro the first
minutes while dave rubin he was
surprised like he was surprising this
and i think it was the ass grab no
surprise dave rubin was homophobic for
me we met and it's like you think he was
dmx or some yeah he was a guy I heard
y'all blank Edwards was having sex with
the same sex I give no love to homo
thugs I'm like oh my god is horrible and
this and no one calls her mother anyway
nobody listen everyone listens to DM
actual lyrics the lyrics wait DMS I
spent like half his life in jail is
criticizing guys we have sex well you
know what they're just looking for it
they're looking for DMX any they don't
call him not our thing I'll call him
non-teflon parking tickets park in if
you just parking a bicycle what a black
over here put your bicycle here man I'm
an El Segundo I thought it'd be fine so
you're going back to the clink oh [ __ ]
quarter black so you're speaking as
though from experience he's like power
thing it's not I know the rules who are
you Johnny you know the rule are you I
don't know I don't know I've claimed to
be nothing I'm just asking questions so
here's my story about ben shapiro
i meet ben shapiro acquisitive at a
hotel in Manhattan Beach I'll just say
it was the Belmont hotel wonderful hotel
best fishing ship ever had my life enemy
I meet his wife she's lovely very pretty
I was I'll be honest this was like pre
famous Ben Shapiro
so I thought wanted to meet his wife was
like you know roll the dice she's very
very pretty and she's very smart very so
I'd meet them like hey let's get out of
here we say well let's go down to the
beach the pier Manhattan Beach Pier and
as we're walking down I realized like
they're walking by my hey guys come on
walk with me they're trailing behind me
there's a pizza place where you get
pizza by the slice down by the pier
there's a couple of but they're skater
kids yeah and they all have shaved heads
and fashionable to be like you sometimes
you wonder when you read these correctly
how do they committed a hate crime I
don't even know that they're Jewish well
if we're benching period well of course
they knew he was Juliet there is no
doubt but you realize I remember go in
like oh wow he does have some concerns
that we don't assert that is an example
of privilege someone who has to be
careful because there could be neo-nazis
getting slices of pizza down at the
Manhattan Beach Pier you never know no
never is a noon hangout but the thing is
Ben was just he was walking behind me
because he knew that if he walked at
that angle you know they couldn't see
him right because well so he's like well
I thought it was Jew Gentile separation
I didn't know jeez well no I want to
talk about the busing integration John
oh thank god coming down on you for
being black racist here's something we
go back to the story okay
myself defend yourself in court against
the fact that you were cleared by a fix
your collar collar my code multiple time
for crying out good where's this stuff
you Hefner's rolling over and syphilis
riddled grave hey gerald
Gerald as the smartest person on the
show yes allowed to say stupid [ __ ] it's
true wait in the realm of theology and
you are very very smart Jill's very
smart we just give jail trap because you
know that's not true not a racist really
a very sincere was racially when I asked
him some questions he would rat me out
yes he would rat me out you only only on
one thing one thing I got your back on
there honking horns at pedophile I would
rest okay I'm sorry but
I told you I go on sex-offender I go in
the sex offender watchlist me and Johnny
boy we find and we don't I don't think
it's a crop we drive by late at night
and for us that's like 10:30 and we honk
the horn Fred and people say well don't
you disrupt the neighborhood we find
very wealthy pedophiles who live on
corner Lots
nobody else is disrupted and you know
what listen I'm sorry it's a small price
to pay for the years of smiles on your
faces which were unwarranted so now honk
okay and I don't read to I don't drive
up in a Yaris I make sure we drive up in
a big ole SUV we're serious honk I
thought about like your Express I'll
show you the airhorn and you do it in
your spawn costume so if Gerald ever
complained about you honking at us no
never he said he would rat me out never
he said he would rat me out he's like I
would write you out if I was ask Mike
what I can't believe that no I would
that's a lie
yeah that is a lie right yeah all we
need to do is get a [ __ ] kid
interrogate him any get enough spit it
right out black Jewish life we're
talking about health care professional
we're talking about medical advice right
Google the Alpha alphabet Google wait
it's alpha better than open eco Facebook
they're removing these doctors who are
seeing patients right now is your doctor
saying hey listen this is what we've
seen with our patients this is what
we've seen with our testing this is the
actual mortality rate this is what we
think would be the best course of action
going forward cannot be allowed you must
go right today at vise right now there's
an article an entire article advising
prescribing their readers on how to use
ketamine which is a one horse
tranquilizer drug and they're a very
dangerous schedule substance I know this
because I've known people who've gone to
ketamine clinics it's use now an anti
depression therapy it is very dose
dependent and it has to be monitored at
an air-tight level and vices like listen
you probably shouldn't do ketamine but
if you are let me break it down for
explain
is this gonna be barred from search on
Google it's instructing kids what's next
how to make pipe bombs I know it's so
they need to stop censoring stuff like
this and especially because they didn't
even watch the doctors because at the
very beginning they said guys all we're
doing is presenting to you information
we're not saying who's right we're not
saying who's wrong we're presenting
information that we have now we don't
have models anymore we actually have
hard data yeah that's all they said
mm-hmm and everybody's coming out
against and there were two agencies to
medical agencies that said that you
don't listen to these guys that just
come out yesterday as well kind of
slamming them and obviously why these
guys aren't saying that we need to up in
oh you can see I have to interrupt you
poppy Harlow by the way I will say this
poppy Harlow still looks very fetching
even with the crappy home make shifts to
be like 4k you know for example that
destroyed kami Diaz's career she's done
right but in this case a lot of late
night hosts look really crappy a lot she
looks great
she's a very pretty lady I just wish he
weren't on the you know the side of the
spectrum with commies but right now
they're saying he oh my gosh that guy
look it's like his nose goes down to his
chin it's a bizarre why is his mouth so
small I know there's a real bird from
Sesame Street it's like his nose was
like hey chin I'm gonna come over at
mouth got it here get away next row next
this is one thing you'll notice by the
way they're moving on to the next
critical equations emergencies
medication shortages are the next big
crisis as though by the way the crisis
is weren't over the crises weren't
averted by private industry we had no
mast
well not only can we sanitize matter not
only we have companies that Septim
certain big masks but you can also make
them from a t-shirt including the one
from the mystery box a bill with two
letters credit merge up calm it and now
they're saying they're gonna be a
shortage of medication there is no
shortage of medication right now
hospitals are not over capacity as a
matter fact I don't lay off and furlough
workers it's time to let hot it's time
to let these heroes as you refer to them
heroes on the front lines it's time to
let the heroes start making money that
means they should be able to go back to
other surgeries other procedures and by
the way kids aren't going into the
pediatric wards right now because
they're afraid of getting coronavirus I
will say so the one the one thing that I
will say that is possibly supportive of
the idea that there will be some types
of commodities shortages is the fact
that we shut down the dang economy yeah
right so so it's like wait a minute
we shut down the economy
now the economy is shut down what a very
interesting point that may play into
that the doctor said what do you think
happens to your immune system when you
shut it down completely based based on
isolation you're shutting down your
exposure to all these positive bacteria
that you get that help you and just to
be clear a month and a half - let me
stop here just to be clear we're not
pulling a diamond and silicon say no
don't wash your hands no no no wash your
hands be sent but there is a worry well
there's a worry that once we reopen
things and we are exposed again will we
have somewhat weakened immune systems
and maybe that's not a huge problem but
statistically we could see a problem
because now we don't have as many
doctors and nurses at the hospital right
we may have some medicine shortages
because we shut the entire economy down
right and we may have more people
getting sick because they're now gonna
get exposed to things that they have
been exposed to and well that's it
that's an example - as to why and we
have to move on to Joe Biden being a
rapist that's a good route you were to
him of Sweden and yeah we've played this
really conservatively on air with it
listen screen didn't do a lockdown at
all they didn't even quarantine the sick
which is what a quarantine is meant to
be right and their numbers weren't worse
than most of Europe and they weren't
better for example wasn't nearly as bad
as Belgium France Italy Spain places
where they did implement full lockdown
so even did nothing and now you were
just saying this that the New York Times
write an article yeah what was it so the
article was talking about it the title
was really funny because you could have
added a question mark at the end it was
like Sweden doesn't follow rest of
Europe and guidelines and just doing
fine at the the article itself and it
talks about how you know for the you
know they really isolated the fact that
it's striking older folks like we talked
about and a lot of folks are talking
about and how you can really aimed
striking older folks right my
coronavirus is showing it looks busty
okay go ahead
so the long short and then I read the
article but it does take an approach
that says hey when you look at the data
certainly there are
some amount of it could be a penetrating
insight okay
not from you and we'll go into Joe Biden
I think we need to hold them to the same
standard as we held Brett cabin I think
that we need to be consistent so at this
of course he's innocent until a court of
law but of course that being said we are
light years ahead of the evidence that
we had with Cavanaugh which is really
just you know as the cops identified it
I would never says lying or Christie
Ford so um in the police after more
women they came forward to sort of
corroborate Tara Reid's story not Joe's
in the pussycats other Tara Reid's Duane
Reade for New Yorkers to go to the
pharmacies not everyone else just
spelled like reading with Annie Biden
held a women's Town Hall good on him
where he never mentioned never addressed
any of the accusation that on which is
often a political strategy but Joe Biden
your history of sniffing isn't going to
go away you can't hide you can't bury it
on a Friday Monday there's sniffs them
so he didn't address the accusations he
did however fall asleep he's just used
to like looking at the floor when he's
around her right here just because he
has mirrored shoes one of my favorite
things is that Hillary Clinton will have
to be called Secretary for the rest of
her life could you give me a coffee
not that kind not administrative
assistant hey so what is it is there
like a country that we think that if you
were you know appointed as the
ambassador it would be punishment and
could we yes petition Trump to assign
Hillary to take that position like yeah
make him ambassador to Ghana yeah yeah
just like federated states of micronesia
yeah I love how a vision bill my lord
kept it general so we did offend any
country and then I just vilified an
entire nation he did it was the first
country Barack Obama visited and
ultimately
this is the top of his priority it's
reversing the Mexico City policy and
going to Ghana really you know there's a
recession Barack going going I think you
funny if they appointed her to Russia
yeah oh yeah how much Joe Biden when he
doesn't win I mean it'll be funny to
point him to anywhere I mean in fact
will you be like you're just the
ambassador to this old folks home go on
it I think we should make an ambassador
to a country that we proactively don't
like yes like here you go it's like
releasing just honey badgers of dementia
look I'm not an international law
scholar but I think it would be a war
crimes it's a violation of the Geneva
can you don't respect the convention at
all so um read by the way she joins
several other women who've been accusing
Biden of inappropriate touching now
senator since 1993 okay so they've been
several women who've come forward and
obviously we have video graphic evidence
of him sniffing small children which I
guess is circumstantial then in a
podcast May sorry March 25th she added
details about him penetrating her with
now I'm you don't say the word and then
she filed a police report so she
actually filed a police report in April
and in April three more people come
forward to corroborate the story they
said that she told him about the assault
back when it happened her brother Colin
her former neighbor Linda Lacasse a
Biden supporter by the way and a former
coworker Lorraine Sanchez something else
April 24th this happened in 2020 I just
have to specify the year because we're
jumping back and forth it's like it's an
Aronofsky film for Nolan take the ones
who like gimmicks Aronofsky's made
nothing good okay your your career was
saved by Mickey Rourke's performance in
the wrestler it wasn't a good film and
Marisa Tomei took her top off give me a
B how hard that is to do a movie idea
time moving back whoa it's precious
there was footage from Larry King Live
which had Tara Reid's mother calling in
which was corroborated it wasn't what's
funny is one of those things where you
can't really save confirmed but when you
watch the media no one argues with it
yeah they just go eh well they said this
and moving on it's your mom it's clearly
her mom we know that your mother and
this was Tara Reid's mother asking of
course Larry King for advice about her
daughter's experience with inappropriate
behavior in Washington backing dating
back to 93 what matters about that
googleplay removed that from the Larry
King catalog we talked about this right
Rosie they removed one episode I think
on August 11th and for some reason they
remembered the rest of the episode so
there was a meeting and there were a
series of decisions finally now we have
a total of eight women who accused your
body of sexual misconduct inappropriate
touching and what really matters of
course is listen like I said we should
hold him to the same standard that we
held Kavanaugh this is way more evidence
than we ever had with Kavanaugh because
the stories all corroborate each other
it's all consistent with Christine Ford
she started naming people who weren't
there in places that didn't even enjoy
that I know like Joe Biden
and if we're going to hold Joe Biden
however to his own standard in 2018 he
said believe all women so if we hold
them but this is what's remarkable to me
if we're going to hold him to his
standard first off it was stupid to say
that you shouldn't believe all anything
no shouldn't know all women all men all
children all Asians all whites you
should say blanket statement believe all
in shirt whatever it is here because uh
neva tably some of them are going to be
lying ass hats there's no way around it
but this is the difference between being
principled and trying to pander for
votes so if we hold them to his own
standard right he has to necessarily
address these claims right now and
provide some evidence which listen he
doesn't need to provide evidence if it's
a court of law because I think we're
past the statute of limitations he's
innocent but when he was calling for
these investigations and other was it
he's innocent and it's really what I
find to be just I completely unabashedly
ironic is when Joe Biden's spokesperson
was asked about this they said we do
think everyone should have the right to
say what they want to say women should
have the right to be able to speak out
about accusations the reporters and
media should vigorously investigate and
FYI
she's a liar right right yeah
I thought to myself wow you guys really
did box ourselves in here growing out
any semblance of justice or evidence or
really doing an investigation or
anything yeah yeah and so and so what's
most interesting as well is the Bernie
the Bernie bros and Bernie ladies they
think they think they're gonna trot out
the Bernie ha ha a convention is just
gonna be the curtain pulled and you're
just gonna see his shoes hanging from a
noose like Brooks and Shawshank there's
no way they're not fade to black it's
crazy it's crazy ooh they're gonna get
in place but look how long have you been
saying it questioning Jose whether he's
all sad I don't harbor any ill will I
think it's really sad it's like a
fighter who's past his prime and you
coach like you great kid no one can
touch you it's like no listen you really
should you should throw in the towel and
if it were my dad you know if it were
one of our relatives I'd like come on
you should really do it yes anymore it's
like you never should have been doing it
in the first place yeah you were gonna
have some kind of problem like this when
you went into it but he so at the time
that the Cavanaugh situation came to
light we everybody was out there like
Alyssa Milano everybody else is tweeting
we can't have this kind of person a
rapist right they were usually very
strong language in office or deciding
you know any any kind of do you know how
we know he's your rapist sometimes he
drinks beer on he does drink beer right
Tuesdays so now we have somebody running
for the Presidency they think that this
is the most important election in the
history of the United States because
we're run by a tyrannical orange man
right yeah and they're not saying
anything at all about this well I
thought it was important to not have a
rapist in office I thought that that was
the line that you said in the sand it
wasn't just about believe everybody
right it was about we don't want this
guy there because he's horrible
and he's already it's just for a second
or the line of questioning right right
now there are all these corroborating
witnesses people by the way many of whom
are saying well you know and I still
probably vote for Joe Biden because I
hate Donald Trump and no one has
investigated there hasn't been a line of
questioning works with Brett Kavanaugh
the authorities come on said you know
what we actually she described a place
that we couldn't find it doesn't really
exist and the therapist it actually
isn't the same as what went out the
Washington Post and it wasn't some story
she gave on the stand and then there
were some people who said I don't know
she's talking about I wasn't even there
and so the questioning the line of
questioning got all the way down to the
point I think it was Cory Booker asking
Brett Kavanaugh do you
like to have a Schlitz on weekdays
Applebee's happy hour perhaps any
earlier than Thursday I rest my case
joe biden's sniffed a child yeah you
don't even need a video you can just
search the gift the Sun isn't rising
anybody and I I hate being that guy who
just says double standard or they Yap
but in this case it really does matter
because they actively try to destroy
somebody's life well the red Cavanaugh
thank you some of being a gang rapists
yes gang rape it's worse than I guess
just being a rapist I don't know I'm not
sure if there's such worse than yeah I
don't know that even question I think
it's bad sounds conflicted I don't know
how much further down the list you can
go I don't know if there's a new bottom
that okay find the bottom then go below
that find another barrel and there's gay
well look what I'm saying to is that you
know what Gerald is not gonna survive
prison I haven't done anything wrong and
a lot of let's go let's go back to like
30 minutes ago
when I was accused of being a racist and
I was not so so I I do I do I do like
the point you're making the jail because
when we when you look at Joe Biden and
you think about okay sure Breck I
haven't always going through an
appointment process they needed to do an
investigation he had a certain role they
were gonna do what they're gonna do but
the way that that was approached was he
is already guilty it doesn't matter any
evidence that is against it we should
throw out and make only the evidence
that as speculative and as weak and thin
as it may be and we're gonna use that to
be the end of it including you drink
beer on Tuesdays right um and then and
then when you look here but I know we
talked about this before the the amount
of the little amount of coverage in
mainstream media and especially those
that are kind of very forward-looking on
the progressive side is terrible I will
say so I think I've mentioned this
before I read a lot of you know both
conservative and non-conservative slate
comm had a really good article that was
just damning
oh I'm not we're gonna say was about how
to inject ketamine but yes well it was
right next to that I was I was down in
the culture right
yeah but but they but they just straight
up they were one of the first ones to
run the the information about the the
neighbor corroborating and giving all
that when CNN wasn't covering it when
the New York Times wasn't covering it
when the Washington Times or The
Washington Post not Washington is
Washington Post was not covering this
well and now the other these other
mainstream media are saying hey we
better start addressing this because
we're gonna lose credibility right you
know or the greatest twist of events is
convention rolls around and they trot
out John Kasich everyone's like [ __ ]
this guy they make a decision that
guarantees everyone is unhappy oh my
John I think they've already done that
with Joe Biden I would love to have John
Kasich trotted out all right we are
going to go to a quick commercial break
before but first we have to read some
chat and then we're going to have the
live roasts from our Jocko correspondent
on jaco willing but let's go to some
chat here what do we have audio yeah so
we have read raises good morning mug
Club I'm really gonna miss these morning
shows makes work tolerable thanks for
all the great content this month it got
me to join up yes and we've alerted your
employer she's working at home that's
not the intent of this program some air
pod pros his bosses and I'm the wiser I
will do my part
give another one good morning good
morning new mug Club member here I love
the morning mug Club shows I love your
roundup of all the BS lame stream news
good use of lame stream we're here John
Romero says thanks for all the great
content and April really helped drown
out all the constant negative press
proud mug club member thank you very
much John Romero we really appreciate it
and I tell you what our Jocko
correspondent has been very good to us
this whole yeah a smooth mani this whole
month and he's been very much looking
forward to this having to read the Jocko
roasts that we have coming up after this
commercial break
that we wrote for him stay tuned Jocko
roasts in just a minute
[Music]
black rifle coffee
[Music]
forward
[Music]
[Applause]
and we are back thank you very much god
what did you Gerald Lee he just got it
can he go did you leave can you go to
the bathroom and I said no no here with
John Kings face I peed on my hands oh
boy I got water really a lot of big
swings in a Miss rottenmeier don't think
it's actually gonna be it's gonna be
hard for me to hand smooth Manny the
jokes here I realized so go me to come
down and hand it you know what no I'll
have a audio way do you think once you
get the levels in there we're good or
okay all right so do we have a stinger
of course for us all right so listen for
folks who don't know oh I should mention
this our Facebook feed got taken down by
I think you're running the clip of those
doctors guideline a few Facebook right
here well Facebook you know you can
that's a good thing I don't really like
to keep the company of serial rapists
it's like get a new things occur Berg
stop with the rape so is that worse than
Gang Rapper's like so it's rape is that
a barrel is more unsightly because it's
okay all right but I don't know he could
be doing with other people he's a
horrible okay so we do have actually to
come in here right now this is our final
installment of the Jocko correspondent
to roast
no no Jocko willing today is smooth
Manny jocular responded let's go
oh there he is or jacket but have you
been doing smooth mani yeah yeah it's
not as much one isn't honest that you
need to talk in 200
so I guess who should we have you know
what half-asian bill let's have you hand
him the jokes here bro so we'll have 1/2
agent bill move over there you can just
stand right next to him so here's what
you gonna do half asian bill this is the
setup ok and then he's gonna read this
and he's gonna turn him around so these
are the right order of the chakra so man
you by the way anything new smooth Manny
on Jacko oh yes well of course but in
like a week and a half
yeah well you thought did doing three
podcasts where Jaco was enough yeah he's
doing a fourth podcast why well the
thread podcast the thread podcast ok and
this deals Jocko podcast isn't
chronological mm-hm so this is actually
going into subjects specifically
chronolock I wish I loved anything as
much as you like Jocko oh and I almost
forgot
yeah if you thought for podcasts during
quarantine was enough for him just
released a new book really load Wow
yes I think I think we can probably get
you to go work for Jocko at some point
the cello to your yo-yo ma okay bill
let's get you will pass him to these one
by one so these are the roasts of Jocko
will link that's why the Asian drivers
they apparently no sense of director the
front side of this card and then the
second side of the card you know because
we just had a love you only don't the
ones you love
so okay Jaco rose for Jaco willing
number one smooth mani choco is popular
for the slogan discipline equals freedom
that's true yeah very much most
importantly in his case the freedom to
conduct weekly costume meetings of his
Lisa Minnelli fanclub Liza Minnelli
films live yeah yeah okay no that's
pretty okay alright let's get into the
groove of this one right sure if I got
that reference
that will be really you just hand them
to Manny and then you can go back bill
so Manny just once once you read and
then you can just turn over that way
bill we have you in that show k Jocko
Roast number two this one doesn't even
make sense
uh-huh of course work you don't trust me
Jocko is not gonna chase you he's not on
the line there you go he's not here just
read it I know it's not your first
language or second language but third or
fourth of course we're laughing we like
to laugh but there's nothing funny about
male-pattern cleft oh geez Wow Wow say
something like that I don't know what
that means yes I will google it
Jocko broadcasts his popular podcast in
black and white it's true he does
harkening back to a simpler time before
the 1964 Civil Rights Act
oh wow racist I start every day doing
the Jocko workout Oh wake up really
early I post a picture of my watch on
Instagram yeah then I go back to bed
until noon well that's just don't
discredit his hard work there's what
Jocko willing calls strong parenting
yeah
Child Protective Services refers to us
minor infraction Jocko willing was born
in Connecticut and moved to California
before serving multiple tours of
commendable service in Iraq made his
command oh yes very much
because Coronado wasn't far enough away
from his gay thoughts yeah Wow hard rows
ties
Jacques biography is nothing short of
all inspiring it is noting that he's
achieved the Honorable rank of
lieutenant commander in the Navy SEALs a
black belt in Brazilian jiu-jitsu and an
impressive height of 511 true all true
the latter statement of which the
Washington Post has rated four
Pinocchios
no sorry Manny
I mean I'm five six yeah they don't get
they don't get any softer no Joker's
Jacko's service record is nothing short
of incredible it is he has been honored
with the Silver Star Bronze Star and his
crowning achievement yeah his graduation
certificate from Mike Pence's electro
camp for the formerly homosexual he is
the best vice president yeah there you
go
jakka famously turned down drugs on Joe
Rogan's podcast which was met widely
with praise yeah it was but should come
as no surprise because you can't smoke
trend alone oh yeah peds yeah heads in
combat in combat chuckle was a
formidable foe striking fear into all
combatants who stood before him in Iraq
he was known as that's Arabic walk Keely
mid dish that's good enough which in its
native Arabic translates to Dudley
do-right banged a serial killer okay and
it's nightly Whitlow's yeah how many
bottles of Jack o discipline go does it
take to screw in a light bulb
disco is supplement Oh none because that
[ __ ] doesn't do anything okay
how do you feel Manny ya feel pretty
good anyway doesn't believe any of these
that yeah I'll tell you a story about
how I feel later Jaakko a leg has now
made a second career as a business
consultant and who the power of
structure and strong leadership helps
identify and turn on struggling
businesses unfortunately he turned them
all into military so surplus stores and
Chippendales in the inventory room next
to the airsoft they have the they have
the Thunder Down Under
which number is 13 okay well how might
we have 18 16 16 we will them down from
like 35 a whole bunch as of 2020 Chaco
has embarked on yet another journey as
an entrepreneur of premium men's denim
where oh wow his jeans include premium
American denim four-way stretch for an
athletic fit and contact tracing suffer
to notify Jaco of your real-time
availabilities in public rest stops oh
wow dad contrary to popular belief Chaco
willing doesn't like the smell of his
own farts he just prefers them yeah
listen everyone has preferences yeah
there's nothing wrong with that his line
of men's work boots are also of the
highest quality that's true yeah with
his future Footwear assisting a premium
American full grain leather handmade
copper rivets as well as built-in
four-inch lifts roast of Jocko willing
from our Jocko correspondent smooth
Manny chuckle where's his notoriety as a
badge of honor he does he is wanted in
three countries for war crimes two
regions for questioning and the state of
Maine for an outstanding late fee on
Magic Mike too
thank you this has been the Jocko Rose
yeah appreciate it and uh how do you
feel about that smooth mani I'm just
upset that it took an entire team of
writers 30 minutes to come up with a
Navy SEAL gage oh well it actually took
far longer than 30 minutes Jocko willing
what do you think about the roast sir
how's it going Manny yeah Manny talk to
your you know tell them that this was
your idea
Jocko what do you did you have anything
to say they're too smooth Manny no I got
nothing to say to Manny okay well we
appreciate it thanks for being a good
yeah words
now that doesn't that looks like it's he
got that at a Dollar Tree gonna go yeah
well jock Manny do you anything you
would like to say to your hero smooth
Manny to Jocko willing I am very sorry I
appreciate the support and I actually
think I might recognize why you're a fan
of me because I didn't understand any of
their jokes either I understand it it
would he's a brave man but it takes an
even braver man to admit his leadership
of the Liza Minnelli fan club so Jocko
not very yet but eventually he will be
we appreciate you brother being here
with us this is the last installment of
good morning mud club tomorrow for our
live stream of CNN not looking forward
to it but we will see you tomorrow I
think it when does it start tomorrow as
it started fine ones the briefings are
usually 5 their time so yeah all right
just checking is announce we will stream
for four hours and live check over CNN
live action thank you so much this has
been a wonderful month it's actually
been a terrible month for me care it's
been wonderful the show wonderful all of
the work is what's difficult you guys
make it worth it we will see you
tomorrow
last day of mud club quarantine god
bless
[Music]